Bradley J bursar is the russell amos
kirk professor in american studies at
Hillsdale College he earned his BA from
the University of Notre Dame and his MA
in PhD from Indiana University he served
on the board of the Free Enterprise
Institute and the Center for cultural
renewal he also serves as fellow or
scholar at the foundation for economic
education the intercollegiate Studies
Institute the McConnell Center in the
center for economic personalism he has
written for numerous publications
including the imaginative conservative a
site he co-founded Ignatius insite
National Review and Catholic World
Report he is the author of several books
including JRR Tolkien's sanctifying myth
understanding Middle Earth American
Cicero the life of Charles Carroll and
in defense of Andrew Jackson please
welcome dr. bruiser
[Applause]
well good afternoon everybody I am very
very honored to be here and to start off
this CCA I've never been able to have
never been asked to speak at a CCA as a
actual participant during the lectures
my department chair who's been very
gracious and has been dean of faculty
has asked me to speak on faculty
roundtables before but this is the first
time I actually get to speak and I get
to speak as the first speaker which is
really really exciting in all kinds of
ways
so Jason thank you so much for that
introduction and I also would like to
thank Matt Bell for inviting me being
the head of the CCA's Doug Jeffery vice
president for external affairs also for
inviting me and for the entire staff at
External Affairs obviously we would not
be here without what they're doing this
is fantastic I do also want to point out
over there though I can't see right now
because of the lighting my my beautiful
wife my lovely wife Deidre is right over
here and she's been bouncing or allowing
me to bounce ideas off of her for
several years now actually maybe more
than we would care to admit and she's
been great I also want to point out my
very lovely Department not lovely sorry
my manly department chair mark calls off
back there as well for being very
supportive okay and I just I have to
point out two other people Tom Connor is
here and he will be on the faculty
roundtable and I actually have nothing
good to say about him I just want to
make sure that when it comes to his turn
to talk about my speech he knows I
recognized him so we will we will leave
it at that okay on a very serious note
as many of you may know when Andrew
Jackson took the oath of office for the
very first time on March 4th of 1829 he
did so wearing all black he was still
lamenting the very recent loss of his
wife his partner his absolute
intellectual equal he also when he gave
his talk when he gave his inaugural he
bowed twice to the American people once
when he started and
once when he finished his talks and both
times he recognized that they were the
true sovereigns of America this was not
affectation or theater on his part one
of the things that astounded me
absolutely and getting to write on
Andrew Jackson is how unbelievably
honest he was and how unbelievably
dedicated he was to the American people
so in 2017 and I don't want to make this
too autobiographical about me but in
2017 I got asked through John Miller who
teaches here at the college he was asked
by Harry Crocker who was the head than
of Regnery publishing if they knew
somebody who could write a very quick
and short biography of Andrew Jackson
I've been teaching Andrew Jackson during
a class that we have here at Hillsdale
College for the last 20 21 years since
1999 I've been teaching a course called
jacksonian america and throughout most
of the time that i had the privilege of
teaching that course which I absolutely
love they're incredible figures like
Ralph Waldo Emerson and Henry David
Thoreau and John Quincy Adams during
much of that I always taught Andrew
Jackson is the bad guy he was the first
really strong executive this was a
person who tried to distort what the
founders wanted he was our seventh
president he was the first non
classically educated president he was
kind of a country bumpkin he was an
Indian murderer
and I taught him basically as that for
roughly eighteen years of my career here
at Hillsdale College so when John Miller
and Harry Crocker asked me to write
about Andrew Jackson I was kind of taken
aback I wasn't quite sure if I could do
this because I know that they wanted a
pretty positive biography especially
because Donald Trump had been making all
kinds of claims very recently especially
on Andrew Jackson's 200th 250th birthday
about the greatness of that president
and I knew that Regnery wanted to kind
of compare Andrew Jackson to Donald
Trump and I decided to go ahead because
I got from Harry Crocker and assurance
that I could write whatever I wanted as
long as I was able to back it up I found
very quickly that I fell in love with
Andrew Jackson almost immediately of all
the people I've had the purple
- right on and I've written only upon
people that I really like
I found that I got to know Andrew
Jackson better than almost every other
figure that I've been able to write
about and the reason was because he
speaks so openly
there is no duplicity in his language in
his mind I actually think it would go
constitutionally against the very
character and the very soul and person
of Andrew Jackson to be duplicitous now
he's also the most brutal person I have
ever come across in my own life in terms
of studying someone this intimately so
he was both incredibly honest and
incredibly brutal and I had to come to
grips with that what is it about this
man and what is it about his brutality
that in many ways plays into his honesty
and what is it about his honesty that
plays into his brutality what I wasn't
expecting and partly because I was in
grad school during the 1990s what I
wasn't expecting was the vigorous
pushback that I was going to get from
academics in even quasi praising any
aspect of Andrew Jackson when I was in
college I graduated college in 1990 and
I finished grad school in 1999 when I
was in college in graduate school Andrew
Jackson was still very well regarded
within the history profession in fact a
poll among historians in 1996 revealed
that most American historians still
regarded Andrew Jackson as one of the
five most important and best presidents
in the United States now that's amazing
because if you go back now in 2020 and
you were to ask historians what they
think of Andrew Jackson he'll be
probably in the bottom 10 to 15 his star
has fallen dramatically and I was told
in no uncertain terms both in interviews
on the radio as well as in critiques of
my own book that defending Andrew
Jackson was no better than defending
Adolf Hitler I do not exaggerate I was
told this several times of course they
never bring up Stalin and I thought well
if you're gonna get nasty brings Stalin
up but they didn't all right
he's too left so only Hitler would do in
the criticism
I was told that Andrew Jackson was a
rapist it's not true I was told he was a
murderer it's not true and I was told he
was an ethnic cleanser it's not true
fascinating what so many people believe
about Andrew Jackson and what struck me
even in the push back on Andrew Jackson
was how absolutely mythic this character
is he is either in American history and
has been either a kind of heroic demigod
the great flag embodied or he has been a
demon in his own days he was called a
knight in buckskin the Napoleon of the
woods Old Hickory and the greatest title
that any American could have held prior
to the 20th century he was the hero of
New Orleans those were all very nice
accolades these were great things that
we saw about his character and I can't
help but think that there's a kind of
American stereotype in the good way
about who Andrew Jackson was he is like
this kind of unrealistic but fascinating
American character he is really the
frontier personified I couldn't help but
think of Johnny Ringo in stage croch
that great John Ford movie and I
couldn't think of yet that help but
think of the innocence of Johnny Ringo
for those of you seen stagecoach and if
you haven't recently you should one of
the great classics in American cinema
Johnny Ringo this young gunfighter finds
himself on a stagecoach with a whole
variety of different people from
different parts of society and one of
the persons on the stagecoach is a
prostitute and Johnny Ringo doesn't get
that he just knows that she's a fancy
woman and he's a woman she's a woman and
he needs to treat her in a certain way
the other woman on the stagecoach is
deeply offended by this I'll come back
to why this is important especially for
Andrew Jackson or I think of John Wayne
again as Ethan Edwards in the searchers
another John Ford movie John Ford and
John Wayne understood something about
this unique
actor the man who loses the man who
struggles no matter the cost but no
matter the loss and no matter the
struggle he continues to fight for
what's right because he knows that's at
the essence of what it means to be an
American male but we could jump forward
a little bit as well and now I'm
probably revealing my own age because I
certainly wasn't around when when
stagecoach or the searchers came out but
I was very much alive and rather in love
with a science fiction story called
Firefly in the early 2000s about 20
years ago and for those of you who've
seen that it is Western set in space and
the main figure is a John Wayne kind of
figure by the name of Malcolm Reynolds
and there's a great moment in the pilot
of that show the show only lasted I
think 16 episodes they did 13 for the
pilot season and then another three and
it failed and then they made a movie
it's unfortunate that have failed but
it's one of those things I'm glad it
existed at all but there's a moment
where a young doctor comes up to the
captain of the ship the Firefly are the
Serenity a Firefly class ship and this
character Malcolm Reynolds is challenged
and the doctor says yeah after all the
violence I've seen are you gonna shoot
me and Malcolm Reynolds says something
to him that's incredible and Andrew
Jackson could have said it he says you
don't know me son so let me explain it
to you once if I ever kill you you'll be
awake you'll be facing me and you'll be
armed now that's the ultimate American
male statement in terms of understanding
what it means to be a smaller Republican
a believer in a republic and to be an
American I think that captures the
essence of it now it's not a normal
statement and yet it's unbelievably
American and for me this is what Andrew
Jackson was all about so I want to make
five points today in talking about
character and leadership in Andrew
Jackson
so Andrew Jackson is born in 1767 and he
dies in 1845
pretty amazing life when you think about
everything that he went through he was
born into absolute poverty scotch-irish
poverty in every way he was able to work
him his way up into the world even
though he had lost the entirety of his
family by the time he was 14 he was able
to work his way up out of poverty and
into not just respectable middle-class
but southern Gentry status in Nashville
Tennessee which I would argue was as
Western and frontier as it was southern
during the age of Andrew Jackson again
those two qualities coming together that
violence of the frontier and that honor
of being a scotch-irish American but I
want to point out five things about
Andrew Jackson as we think about him in
his career number one I think very
importantly he was all of his life a
smaller Republican he believed in the
essence of a republic he was a
Presbyterian and he was Scotch Irish and
I think in many ways that identification
of his ethnicity and his religion and
his politics reveals much about who the
man was his mother as I mentioned died
when he was young he was only 14 and his
mother died because she was nursing
American soldiers during the American
Revolution and caught a fever and was
not able to overcome it but she did
leave some advice for Andrew whom she
hoped would grow up to be a Presbyterian
minister it was actually one reason that
they saved up their money very little
that they had for Andrew to be able to
go to a liberal arts college when he was
a young man I he didn't use the money
for that it went for other things Andrew
Jackson did end up having somewhat of a
classical education but as he himself
said everything that he ever needed to
know he learned by reading stories of
William Wallace the great Scottish
nationalists and there's something to
that especially when we think about
Andrew Jackson but here's what his
mother wrote him before she died as a
piece of advice so point number one
being Republican scotch-irish
Presbyterian and being the son of this
woman Andrew if I should never see you
again
and I wish you to remember and treasure
up some things that I have already said
to you in this world you always have to
make your own way to do that you have to
have friends you must make friends by
being honest and you must keep them by
being steadfast you must keep in mind
that friends worth having will in the
wrong run long run expect as much from
you as they give to you to forget an
obligation or to be ungrateful for a
kindness is a base crime not merely a
fault or a sin but an actual crime men
guilty of this crime sooner or later
suffer the penalty in personal conduct
be always polite but never obsequious
none will respect you more than you will
ever respect yourself avoid quarrels as
long as you can without yielding to
imposition but sustain your manhood
always never bring a suit of law for
assault or battery or defamation to a
courtroom the law affords no remedy for
such outrages that can satisfy the
feelings of a true man
everybody catch that you beat the snot
out of your opponent on the street you
don't take him to court hey this is this
is what it means to be a real man of the
law never wound the feelings of another
never Brooke once an outrage upon your
own feelings if you ever have to
vindicate your feelings or defend your
honor do it calmly and then if angry
wait until your wrath cools before you
proceed
now what motherly advice right there we
have it and Andrew loves this this is
everything to him and one of the most
fascinating things I found in going
through the life of Andrew Jackson was
how much to an almost surrealistic
degree he respected women now this is a
great thing right we should respect
women men should respect women but
Jackson took this to the point where his
mother and his wife who is his
intellectual equal in
whay and his partner he took it so far
that I have never seen anyone in history
thinks so highly of a woman except for
maybe Roman Catholics in the way they
approach the Virgin Mary and I say that
without any kind of recrimination just
straightforward Jackson had a great
reverence for women so if you remember I
brought up a little bit ago Johnny Ringo
on the stagecoach we find letters in
Andrew Jackson's collected letters where
he wrote to the prostitutes of Nashville
Tennessee inviting them to the town
balls not as dates but as equals because
they too were citizens or at least
residents of Nashville wasn't a joke it
wasn't meant in any way to be derogatory
Andrew truly believed that this was how
you treated women and we could say and
this was something that was brought up
against the Andrew Jackson in his own
lifetime and today
well what about black women I was a
slave owner we have the testimony of one
of his slaves Hannah who said that every
time Andrew Jackson came to the
plantation everybody celebrated he
solved problems he served as a judge he
treated all of his slaves with respect
he rolled up his shirtsleeves and worked
with them in every way and not only that
but when Rachel Jackson passed away in
1829 and Jackson had to leave his estate
to go up to Washington to be president
he'd left Hannah his black slave in
charge of the estate for the eight years
that he was gone it's pretty impressive
kind of complicates our view of slavery
there it is very very interesting point
number two about Andrew Jackson as I
mentioned earlier Jackson was as honest
as he was violent and one of the things
that shocked me to no end and I will
admit I'm from Kansas I'm a Volga German
Russian German stock my family refused
to fight during World War one which my
wife's family still likes to tease me
about because they have fought in every
every encounter America's been and I
think going back to like Queen Anne's
war so they have been in everything
very proudly so my family has done
everything to dodge war in every way so
this is not from my background in Kansas
but I think about the complex set of
rules that went around dueling during
the 1800s and how complicated this was
Andrew Jackson once said for malicious
slander all men are answered only at the
bar of honor now think about what his
mother told him anytime you're wrong do
you never take it to court you settle it
in the street that's what real men do
and that's exactly what Andrew Jackson
did but there's something about
Jackson's duels that are absolutely
fascinating
the duels dictated that no people ever
of unequal worth could challenge one
another in a duel and Jackson has in his
own letters and his diaries that when
younger men who were clearly trying to
make their way in society and prove
their worth within scotch-irish society
when they would challenge Jackson
Jackson would actually go up to him in
the street with his cane and just beat
them he would tell them you're not
worthy of a duel but someday you will be
and it was actually to be caned by
Andrew Jackson was regarded as a good
thing and here's why because it meant
that you would mean something someday
even if you don't yet if Jackson ignored
you that was the worst thing possible
here's one of the most interesting
comments I'll give you two stories about
Jackson and dueling when he was in the
US Senate and he only served twice in
the US Senate and neither for a full
term just a couple of years in the 1790s
and then yet and then again in the 1820s
he just served for about two years each
but the first time that he was in he was
enduring John Adams administration and
he was absolutely disgusted by a fight
that was going on not a real fight but
an a political argument going on the
floor of the Senate that lasted for 16
days and Jackson writes in his diary I
don't I don't get this these men are a
feat this is all sticks and
it´ll we have spent 16 days of the
people's money spending $10,000 for this
debate and what an absolute disgrace
they could have easily solved it by a
quick duel outside of Congress now he
means this this is not a joke on his
part right this is the way men settle
things and I have to admit and I don't
consider myself an extremely violent
person but when I looked at how
complicated the rules were in society
and how detailed the instructions were
on who you could fight and who you
couldn't fight there is something
honorable in what Jackson is advocating
I'm not calling for a return please I
can see people now Hillsdale professor
calls for return to dueling this is not
what I'm doing but I do want to put it
into the context of the times that there
is something fascinating about what's
going on but here's my favorite
challenge Andrew Jackson as you may know
was extremely intelligent but not very
well educated and one of the funniest
things about going through his letters
is he never spells the same word the
same way twice right now and I think he
would have considered it a badge of
dishonor
had he been able to spell consistently
but he would write these challenges in
the in the Nashville newspaper where he
would say because of this person's
actions I challenged this person to a
duel for whatever reason and he would
list it and then he would say I call on
this person to give me a time and a date
and one of the persons that he got into
a fight with was the governor John
Sedlar
and so they were trying to figure out a
time and they kept sending and I've seen
all these notes they're hilarious they
keep sending these notes back to each
other saying well I think we should
fight by longsword we'll do it at this
place at this time the other one will
write back no long swords not
appropriate I say we use this caliber
pistol we'll do it at this time and they
went this went on for weeks and Jackson
got really frustrated and so he finally
published in the newspaper to all whom
shall see this present greetings know ye
that I Andrew Jackson do pronounce
publish and declare to the world that
the excellency John see Savior
severe your governor captain general
commander-in-chief of the land and naval
forces of the state of Tennessee is a
base coward he will basically insult but
he has not the courage to repair the
wound
now there's the final statement and so
Savior agrees and they come up on a time
and Jackson is anxious about this duel
and they have to do all right on the
Tennessee Kentucky border they don't
want to be either exactly in Kentucky or
Tennessee in case the law decides to get
involved so they picked this spot on the
Kentucky Tennessee border
Jackson shows up earlier early he's got
his number two you always have a second
with you in case you fall who can pick
up the fight and he sees about 15
minutes late said you're riding in on a
horse with a friend his number two and
Jackson is furious because the guy's
late and so Jackson pulls his cane
remember the cane he pulls his cane out
and he charges savior' charges him
across this field and Savior is so
befuddled by this that he tries to pull
his sword out but in the act of trying
to pull his sword out he falls off his
horse
and he falls onto the ground on top of
his sword and his sword breaks into
Jackson comes up to him and says I see
you removed your sword
I consider this duel satisfied
they shook hands rode back to Nashville
together and became constant allies for
the rest of each of their career be how
do we explain this in politically
correct 2020 I can you imagine on
Twitter oh you scoundrel
all right point number three and
specifically about the context of this
great CCA on character and leadership in
the military one of the most interesting
things about Andrew Jackson but I think
we often don't remember about him is
that he actually had a great animosity
towards the standing army even though he
was a general within the standing army
he wrote constantly throughout his life
he didn't write he wrote lots of letters
he didn't write a lot of public
documents but he did a few and in these
statements that he wrote about the
standing army he had kind of the
old-fashioned smaller Republican notion
that a true Republic will be defended by
its Navy it can be permanent but never
by a standing army which is almost
always the tool of oppression as he
thought he said there really only two
reasons to call up the army and you
never have it for more than two years
right and this is in the Constitution we
know that no bill that gives revenue to
the army can last for more than two
years there are no such restrictions on
the Navy but there is that in the US
Constitution Jackson said there are only
two reasons we would ever call up the
standing army number one if the Indians
are harassing us or number two if the
Europeans are is not expecting anyone
else but if the Europeans or the Indians
and even then when we call up the
standing army we always put limitations
on it and we always make sure that the
militia is superior to the standing army
here he is in 1805 during his July 4th
toast in Tennessee he says and this is
toast number oh I'm sorry I did not
write this it's toast number seven and
it actually mattered the number of
toasts because I'll read you seven and
then 11 so
toast number seven to the militias of
the United States the surest bulwark of
freedom and then number eleven to the
army of the United States which we must
always remember can be doomed to
persecution and tyranny under a
government of laws to satiate the
private spleen of any would put it would
be despot so that's pretty amazing we're
praising the army but not really because
we don't know exactly what that army is
gonna do five years later in 1810 he
explained his own position in a letter
to the governor of Tennessee he says our
independence and liberty as a people was
not obtained without expense it was
dearly bought with blood and treasure
and it must be preserved the Pence on
this subject can never be counted but
the only real and substantial defense of
a free people is the organized militia
this is always and I quote from Jackson
in contrast with the corruption
manifested at all times in our Regular
Army and this has been verified by our
Constitution which only allows the
two-year funding for things in the Army
in 1812 and 1813 when Andrew Jackson
called
up his own private militia and state
army within Tennessee he told them that
no matter what he assured them he would
not allow the federal government to
federalize them in any way he said to
his men in March of 1812 there will be
no drafts or compulsory levies and if
they are made there will be a simple
invitation to those who buy into that
idea to leave to us the fighting so if
you've been drafted if you're here
against your will we'll ask you to leave
Jackson when he was told by the
Secretary of War that he must federalize
his troops he refused and he said this
is not what I promised the parents of
these young men these young men are here
strictly because they believe the fight
is correct and he refused to follow the
order of John Armstrong then the
Secretary of War
and he said I would remind you of your
own Army's success was it not under the
US Army command of William hull at
Detroit in 1812 that you surrendered a
third of our forces to the British where
is your glorious army and by what right
do you have to regulate my militia he
says a nobler feeling should impel us to
action who are we what are we going to
fight for are we the slaves of George
the third this is in 1813 are we the
slaves of George the third or the
military conscripts of Napoleon or the
frozen peasants of the Russians are no
we are Freeborn sons of the Republic of
America the citizens of the only
republic now existing in the world and
the only people on earth who possess
rights liberty and property which they
dare call their own
it's amazing and think about that and I
hope this is one of those things we
rarely teach in our classrooms I hope we
have to understand and explain that this
is a different world and when Jackson is
against the military in this kind of
audience that I have right here in front
of me this is this is odd to us but when
we imagine what the history of standing
armies had been at the time that Jackson
speaks in 1812 and 1813 we can
understand why he's so hesitant about
this but he takes this even further when
he is inaugurated on March 4th of 1829
he will not allow any military officers
to be present and if they're present
they may not be in uniform but he does
invite all the militias of the present
day and of all those who fought during
the Revolutionary War to come and parade
and he walks with them during his
inaugural that's a that's astounding in
all kinds of ways okay point number four
well despite this Andrew Jackson is one
of the greatest victors in US history
and we can think about what he did on
January 8th of 1815 and I would remind
everyone here that Jackson's force was a
force of all
mm that he had at the Battle of New
Orleans and it was Jackson almost alone
who understood that after the British
had invaded in the Great Lakes and then
up the Chesapeake their next venue would
be Mississippi very few people believed
that was going to be the case we were in
the middle of signing a piece in the
fall an early winter of 1814 with
Britain Britain had just concluded
hostilities by defeating Napoleon and we
thought this was it Jackson knew better
he knew that the British would do one
last thing we also know this that when
the British were given orders and there
were 14,000 troops being carried on 60
ships under the leadership of Ned
Pakenham coming from Britain these were
all Napoleonic soldiers battle-hardened
these were not draftees these were not
new recruits these were men who had seen
much action in Europe throughout the
Napoleonic Wars and they had expressed
permission from both Parliament and the
king that when they were to attack it
was not to be a harassment raid it was
to be an attack to reclaim property all
along the Mississippi River that's
something we often forget about in
history this was not meant to be some
harassment run the British were here for
blood and for our soil and Jackson
understood this he knew that this was
coming and so he and what would resemble
modern trench warfare what we will see
at Petersburg during the Civil War are
what we'll see at the Battle of the
Somme and other great battles in World
War one he created massive trenches
waiting for the British to come and
again remind us of that force Jackson
has just a little over 2,000 men all
recruits all free he refused to allow
any draftees with him at all he would be
a party would he would find that up hor
n't so he has only about 2,000 men then
2,000 men but they are in great
battle-hardened mode behind these
trenches and these dugouts well one of
my favorite historians was actually a
journalist before he became a minister
and Paul Johnson writes in his excellent
book from 1991 the birth of the modern
he describes how terrible the British
were in executing this plan at New
Orleans
he says the great Duke of railing of
Wellington PAC and ham had married his
sister Catherine but that was the
closest that that man had ever gotten to
any military mastery money in Connexions
had made packing ham a major before he
was seventeen and a colonel at age 21
there was no question of his courage
serving as a major-general under his
brother-in-law at Salamanca in 1812 he
had been given the chance when
Wellington told him to take his division
straight at the French Center with the
words now's your time Ned Ned broke
through the French line in this
Wellington said in a dispatch won the
battle though he admitted quote packing
ham may not be the brightest of geniuses
he launched a full frontal assault on
Jackson's position on January 8th of
1815 Andrew Jackson and his own report
says that he had about ten of his own
men killed and about ten woudn't wounded
total 20 casualties at a 2,000 the
British that day lost 1,500 Marines and
another 500 who were taken prisoner
imagine that there were close to 44
bodies that were so decimated in the
Gulf of Mexico that they could not find
the remains of them they couldn't
identify this is incredible
and what do we have and what comes out
of this and this is where no matter what
even if we remembered Andrew Jackson for
nothing else he is the hero of New
Orleans was he lucky maybe was he smart
maybe did he win he won brutally he won
and so what does Paul Johnson say Paul
Johnson who is British himself says this
was the great moment in anglo-american
relations
it was at this moment alone that the
British finally took us seriously as a
country it was at this moment that the
great anglo-american alliance which had
blasted and still does up till 2020 but
certainly at the time that Johnson wrote
this in 1991 this was the beginning of
our mutual respect with each other and
you think about Andrew Jackson
he's now as great as William Wallace
he's now as great as James Wolf
he is truly one of the great generals in
history at that point and more than any
other title he had the title that meant
the most to him and the one that meant
the most to Americans always was that he
was the hero of New Orleans finally
point number five and I'll conclude with
this and we'll open it up for questions
one of my favorite things about Andrew
Jackson so today you'll have to forgive
me for this but I wore and I don't know
how many of you can see this but I wore
my grandfather who was the best man I
ever knew
he died in 1982 but I wore his campaign
button for Dwight the Eisenhower from I
don't know if it's from 52 or 56 but
it's from one of those elections and
I've had it with me I've never worn it
before is the first time I've worn it
and I thought we're here to talk about
character we're here to talk about
American generals what better figure
other than Andrew Jackson than Dwight
Eisenhower you know what what a great
thing and I grew up in Kansas I've been
to the eyes and our museum a million
times so you guys will please forgive me
I've already given you Jackson's views
on the military and they're probably not
so well taken necessarily in this
audience and understandably so but I
would also give another view of Andrew
Jackson and something that I think we
often forget but should remember at the
end of Andrew Jackson's life he died in
1845 as I mentioned earlier people his
friends offered to build him a mausoleum
so that they could dedicate at least
some memorial to him as hero of New
Orleans and as president of the United
States
and Jackson writes them back and he says
I am so
honored that you would want to remember
me after my death but I must decline any
memorial my own Republican feelings and
my principles of republicanism forbidded
and the simplicity of our way of life as
a republic should forbid it true virtue
cannot exist where pomp and parade are
governing passions
it can only dwell with the people the
great laboring and producing classes
that form the bone and the sinew of our
Republic thank you very much
thank you dr. bruiser you're welcome
wherever you are really oh there you are
thank you we now have time for Q&A
please make your way to the microphone
if you have a question doctor could you
say something about the Bank of the
United States I'm sorry could you repeat
that please
could you say something about Jackson
and the Bank of the United States oh
sure yeah so the question about Jackson
in the bank of the United States is a
great one because obviously and it's not
something I focused on since we're
dealing with military history but it's
related Andrew Jackson in his honesty
and I think we could probably debate
this but people at the Mises Institute
and Ron Paul would agree with this
Jackson's argument was essentially that
money must be real if it's not actual
specie that is if it's not based on a
physical commodity it's a lie this was
part of Jackson's honesty and he truly
he was a gold man in every way gold
silver whatever it is that we wanted to
trade in but it had to be a commodity
and so from the very beginning of that
the first bank of the United States
Jackson had vehemently opposed it when
he was a young man he opposed the second
bank of the United States and of course
when he's president he can actually do
something about this and when the Whigs
tried to out move out maneuver him
during his first administration and have
the bank come up four years early for
renewal for a 20-year renewal Jackson
uses this to solidify so empower in fact
in some ways Jackson really becomes
Jackson as president after his victory
against the second bank of the United
States and he makes two arguments he
says number one ultimately this is a lie
paper money is always and everywhere a
lie even if you could have paper money
effective for a certain amount of time
it will always become corrupt at some
point because it's not worth anything
it's only worth what we stayed it's
worth
and therefore it can't have any
longevity but the second point he made
to this was a very interesting one and
one I think that we've those of us who
love the free market should remember his
argument was that power really rarely
benefits the poor it almost always
benefits the rich and what was the bank
second bank of the United States founded
for not to create equality among the
peoples of America but to give privilege
to the wealthy and he actually argued
through much of his own arguments on
government privilege that that's the
thing that we must most be concerned
about the poor will always be here they
will come and go but they'll never
really have any long-term say over the
government he thought but the rich would
and we had to be very careful of that
but he's coming from a radically less a
fair argument on that which I find very
interesting so thank you for that
question
where is that coming from here sorry the
question is to the speaker's left
professor sir my name is Gordon Austin
I'm a retired naval officer and I came
from Georgia specifically to hear this
series and I want to compliment you on
getting it off to such a good start
thank you you alluded to what my
question is at the beginning I recently
visited the Hermitage and I was struck
by the comparison between Donald Trump
and Andrew Jackson especially in
contemporary descriptions of Jackson
could you expound on that sure so one of
the reasons that I did write my book was
simply because there was so much
interest in drunk a Trump being
interested in Jackson and if you go back
and look so Donald Trump gave his speech
on Andrew Jackson's 250th birthday and
it's actually one of I think one of
trumps more really well done speeches I
don't think it would compare the one
that he gave at the the right-to-life
March was I if we remember him for
anything it will be for that speech
which was probably written by Hillsdale
graduate Brittany Baldwin most likely
I'm she is his speechwriter on all
things religious so I assume that she
can't take credit for that so I will
give her credit I'm pretty sure she's
the one who wrote that an amen
but this the speech he gave on Jackson
was really quite interesting
it's three years old coming up on three
years and there been a lot of questions
about what's the similarity and most of
the people who were commenting on the
similarities have done so because they
both come at these populist moments
these moments where people are trying to
take back what's going on in Washington
DC there's no question I can't speak as
effectively on Trump
there is no doubt that when Andrew
Jackson went to DC he cleaned the place
up Andrew Jackson actually has a squeaky
clean record we may not always agree
with his policies I heard someone yell
out the Trail of Tears and yeah there's
no real defense of that there's an
explanation but not a defense of its
it's heinous but when we look at his his
actual practices he's squeaky clean
we don't have examples of corruption in
his administration at all and he there
were things like he put in charge of all
the bureaucrats in Washington he put a
guy in charge by the name of Amos
Kendall and Kendall used to walk around
from office to office and if he thought
anybody was wasting government time if
they were reading a newspaper or a novel
or if they were just sitting there he
fired him this you can't do this you're
on the people's dime you're working or
you're out and there's no doubt Jackson
spent his eight years in Washington
cleaning things out and if I remember
correctly he's the only president
outside of Clinton to have fully
balanced the budget yeah and he he was
very effective at this and a lot of it
had to do with these policies of
corruption I don't think Trump has been
quite as effective but there are reasons
for that the bureaucracy is much deeper
then it was under Andrew Jackson things
were still very politicized under Andrew
Jackson you either were the follower of
the President or you weren't and if you
weren't you lost your job and it didn't
matter if you were in DC or a postal
carrier you were out and so there was no
civil service tenure other than what the
president said if you're in an executive
office the other thing that they have in
common of course is they're both
Scottish and they have that they have
that kind of tendency that tendency to
speak off the cuff at times
they also are interesting and I don't
want to get too political about this but
you know when it comes to women they
both have interesting relations with
women but I would say Jackson's were a
lot more traditional than then Trump's
have been so I don't want to get too
much more into detail about that but
yeah so I don't know if that answers you
but you know their policies aren't that
they're not totally that similar I mean
when we think about Jackson being so
anti military and so Pro free trade and
so less a fair I think Trump's been
really good on the less a fair part
especially with the regulatory offices
but at those other things I mean he's
clearly not been free-trade by any means
good or bad that he's different from
Jackson in that way so thank you very
much for your question over here thank
you thanks very much for your talk at
the very introduct and your introductory
mark she talked about the reputation of
Jackson being a rapist and an Indian
murderer you know I really know nothing
about Jackson's but could you talk about
where did those stories come from if
they weren't true so a lot of them came
from his political opponents at the time
they used to they used to report things
like this they'd have Jackson for
president do you want a murderer in the
White House things like that but we do
remember him and there's there's no easy
defense of this and he clearly is
responsible for the removal of thousands
upon thousands of Indians from their
traditional homelands to the west and
they were removed if they were from the
southern colonies other-- n-- states
they were removed to Kansas excuse me
Oklahoma and from the northern places
like here Hillsdale when the Potawatomi
were removed or removed to Kansas around
Topeka and he is responsible for that
now
he'd we can look at his arguments he did
believe very strongly that removal was a
preferable option to keeping them where
they were where they would keep getting
surrounded now populated by those of
European descent but the execution of
the removal was heinous when we look for
example at the Choctaw Indians one of
the five major tribes of the south that
was removed to Oklahoma
when they were removed in 1831 in 1832
they started off with 18,000 people in
their tribe a year later they were down
to 6,000 they lost 2/3 of their people
in their removal I just
there's no defense of that I think a lot
of it had to do with poor execution
rather than actual intent of the policy
but regardless you know that Jackson has
to be held accountable for that at some
level we have to be able to recognize
that now interestingly enough I mean
those people who survived if you look at
Indian drives the Choctaws became the
single wealthiest Indian tribe by the
1850s and 1860s but then of course they
sided with the Confederacy and yeah it's
this stuff is very very complicated in
fact more Indians own slaves per capita
than white Americans did we never say
that to our children that's just it and
I'm not trying to condemn anyone in
particular it just makes the story
really really complicated
there's no evidence of the rape I
actually was I was on a radio show one
of the first that blew it I did a
horrible job if any of you finding it
was any of you want to see me do a
terrible job at something and hopefully
I didn't tonight but I I'm this if you
get on just going to youtube and do Brad
burrs or interview Andrew Jackson this
will pop up and I was horrible at it
this guy came up he said well Andrew
Jackson's a rapist and all this and I
was so taken aback here I'd spent all
these all this time writing this book is
like wait a minute I had not heard any
of this so I did a quick search of
Andrew Jackson rapist on Google and the
first eight of the first ten results
were of a rape in a public school called
the Andrew Jackson school in Georgia and
I don't know if that's where it came
from but I'm guessing because there was
nothing in his lifetime where anyone
ever suggested that at all in fact if
anything people made fun of him for
being so taken with his wife they they
didn't they actually was one of those
few things where they thought Jackson
wasn't manly enough because his wife
commanded him around and she didn't
command him but they were they were
definitely equals no question and I
wouldn't
with her either she was a fierce person
I mean devout hardcore bible-thumping
presbyterian from day one but you know
that I think she's amazing
and I'm shocked there aren't more books
about her she's one and she was very
liberally educated actually in a great
writer so I can't believe I get I don't
know why people ever written about her
they should she's a great person so I
hope that answers you yeah thank you we
have time for one more question sure
thank you dr. bird sir my question is
it's about General Jackson rallying
troops to defend New Orleans with the
recent purchase of the Louisiana
territory under the Jefferson presidency
how what what did General Jackson have
to do to win the support of the locals
of New Orleans especially with the
change in loyalties right so you know
it's very interesting we we don't there
are a lot of things we have a lot of
good evidence about what he did there
and I would really recommend I only in
my my book on Jackson I only spend about
four pages on this it's I think it's
really important but I just kind of get
at the mythical element if any of you
are interested this fox news
correspondent Brian Kilmeade has written
a book on on Jackson at New Orleans and
I think it's it's an excellent book it
is very well researched and beautifully
written and this is he deals exactly
with this so I don't want to defer I
don't want to not answer your question
but really that's if you want to look at
that I think he's probably the best of
current writers dealing with that but
Jackson I mean there was no doubt that
there was some opposition to what he was
doing especially this is Jackson he
walked into town it's basically his town
he comes in with his militia and they're
not even from that area remember these
are Tennessee guys right but he's able
to recruit some people within the area
but he mostly tells the citizens of New
Orleans just to stay away he doesn't
want them near the battle on his side or
out he wants his men whom he can trust
and by the way just to get to the
question that was asked a moment ago it
is very interesting Andrew Jackson's
army was made up was mostly white
Tennesseans but about a third of it was
free blacks
Indians who were his allies yeah we
don't again this one of those things we
don't often talk about he has a it's a
motley crew it's an interesting and even
recruits some pirates very famously John
Lafitte from the area who decided who
decided to fight with him and do very
success they're very successful at this
but Jackson more or less puts it's not
official but he more or less puts New
Orleans under martial law
during the time he can't regulate it
it's something he just has to depend
that they'll do but he basically tells
them don't bother with us we won't
bother with you and of all the people
their crazy stories that come out of
this this miracle at New Orleans but one
group of Newark you think about these
are these are French I had in Spanish
who were living there the people who
opened the most there's a convent of
nuns there who for whatever reason think
Andrew Jackson is this great guy and I'm
guessing he treated them pretty well and
they actually they were running food to
the poor and taking care of things while
he was not in town and I had nuns in
grade school they they can be wonderful
and they can be fierce and I'm sure I'm
sure martial law would have been
preferable so thank you thank you very
much everyone
you